WEIGHTLIFTING THEN IN NEW
ZEALAND?
MAY BE SETH MEYERS FANS.
AND WHO KNEW NEWAND AT AN
OLYMPIC TEAM.
AND KNOW THEY HAVE A GOVERNMENT.
THEY ARE QUITE AS STURDY BUNCH.
SO OUT OF 7 BILLION PEOPLE, THE
TRANS ATHLETE IS GETTING A LOT
OF SPACE VERY DON'T GET ANGRY
ABOUT ANYTHING IF THE PEOPLE
CLOSER TO THE ISSUE AREN'T ANGR
FIRST.
I CAME UP WITH AT ROYAL OAK WEE
AFTER I WAS MARRIED TO.
MEANING, IF THE PEOPLE DIRECTLY
IMPACTED BY THIS STUFF AREN'T
WILLING TO STEEP SPEAK UP, THEN
WHY SHOULD I.
MAY BE THEIR MAT THEY CAN'T SAY
SO BECAUSE THEY'RE SCARED FOR
THE VERY SAME REASONS EVERYONE
IS SCARED TODAY.
THEY DON'T WANT TO BE OSTRACIZE
FOR THEIR BELIEFS.
IN THE MODERN ERA OF BEING WOKE
A PEOPLE EXPERIENCE THAT ALLOWS
THEM TO SPEAK OUT, THEY GET
SWARMED BY THE MOB.
SHE HAD TO APOLOGIZE FOR
DEFENDING AND NONWHITE DIRECTOR
FOR NOT BEING WOKE ENOUGH.
WE'RE TALKING WAY FEMALE
WEIGHTLIFTERS, WHY SHOULD THEY
BE SCARED OF ANYONE?
THEY CAN CRUSH YOU WITH THEIR
THIGHS.
AND THEY CHARGE A LOT FOR THAT
ON CRAIGSLIST.
FOR PEOPLE WHO SHOULD BE GETTIN
UPSET ABOUT COMPETING AGAINST
TRANS ATHLETES SHOULD BE THEIR
SIGNIFICANT OTHERS AND THEIR
COWORKERS AT THE POSTAL SERVICE
PART IF THEY CAN'T VOICE THEIR
OPINIONS BECAUSE THEY FEEL
ATTACKED BY HARD-CORE ACTIVISTS
WHO HOW CAN WE HELP.
PEOPLE CRITICAL OF TRANS
ATHLETES BRING UP THE HARD WORK
I LOGICAL WOMEN PUT INTO THEIR
IT'S HARD TO SEE THEM LOSING
THEIR SPOT TO A.
THERE IS A REASON PEOPLE TAKE
WILL HORMONES TO ENHANCE
PERFORMANCE.
YOU COULD HAVE SEPARATE TEAMS
FOR MALE, FEMALE, AND TRANS, YO
COULD DO AWAY WITH ALL CRITERIA
ALTOGETHER AND LESS HUMANS
PLAYED TOGETHER LIKE COED SOCCE
BACK IN SCHOOL.
BUT EXCEPT A REAL SPORT.
BUT EVEN IN THOSE GAMES YOU
CAN'T IN THE ESCAPE THE INNATE
DIFFERENCES.
MEN AND WOMEN ARE DIFFERENT.
SOMETHING I HAVE TO REMIND
MYSELF WHEN I ACCIDENTALLY WALK
INTO THE WRONG, AT PLANET
FITNESS.
IT'S NOT COMMON IN HEAD-TO-HEAD
SPORTS TO HAVE MEN COMPETE
AGAINST WOMEN DUE TO PHYSIOLOGY.
BUT YOU CAN OPEN UP THE LIKE EG
PARTY AT KAT'S BIRTHDAY.
IN EQUESTRIAN SPORTS, THEY
DIRECTLY COMPETE, AND THE NCAA
MEN AND WOMEN COMPETE AGAINST
ONE ANOTHER IN RIFLE SHOOTING,
WHICH IS GREAT PREP WORK IF YOU
PLANNING TO MOVE TO CHICAGO.
THERE IS ULTIMATE FRISBEE WHICH
ALLOWS PEOPLE OF DIFFERENT
GENDERS TO MATCH UP AND PLAY,
USUALLY BETWEEN THEIR AT HOT
TOPIC.
BUT AFTER THAT, MY ANALYSIS
COLLAPSES LIKE CHINESE MADE LAW
ORNAMENT.
THOSE ARE THE EXCEPTIONS WHICH
MIGHT PROVE THE RULE, WE ARE
DANCING AROUND THE 400-POUND
WEIGHTLIFTER IN THE ROOM.
SEXISM, IT IS EVERYWHERE.
BUT, DIFFERENCES ARE EVERYWHERE
INCLUDING THIS SPORT.
THAT IS CURLING.
MAY BE THIS SPORT SHOULD BE
FEMALE BECAUSE IT INVOLVES A
BROOM AND SWEEPING.
IT IS SOMETHING A SEXIST MIGHT
SAY AND SOMETHING THAT I WOULD
CONDEMN.
WE LIVE IN A TIME WHERE WE CAN'
SPEAK THE TRUTH, THE GULF
BETWEEN OUR THOUGHTS AND WORDS
IS DEEPER THAN AN LIMBIC HOCKEY
FIELD AND IT'S GETTING WHITER.
YOU GETS A SHAME BECAUSE WE CAN
GET WE COULD MAKE PROGRESS IF W
WERE OPEN ABOUT THE PROGRESS
ITSELF.
LET'S WELCOME TONIGHT'S GUEST.
HER PREFERRED PRONOUN IS WINNER
CALIFORNIA GUBERNATORIAL
CANDIDATE CAITLYN JENNER.
THIS MERCEDES HAS LIBERALS
LOOKING LIKE FIATS, AMERICAN
SURVEY UNION FELLOW MERCEDES.
HER TONGUE IS SO SHARP, SHE'S
ONLY EVER EATEN GRATED CHEESE.
CAITLIN,.
>> I'M HERE.
>> I WOULD SAY HERE.
>> I KNOW, BUT WE TALKED A
COUPLE OF WEEKS AGO.
>> I THOUGHT WE KIND OF BONDED.
>> I THINK WE DID.
I THOUGHT IT WAS GREAT.
>> WHEN YOU SENT ME THOSE PHOTOS
.
>> WERE YOU EXCITED ABOUT THEM?
TO GET I WAS EXCITED THREE OR
FOUR TIMES OVER THE COURSE OF A
EVENING.
>> BEFORE WE GET STARTED I HAVE
PERSONAL FOR YOU.
I WOULD LIKE TO KNOW THE ANSWER
TO THIS AND I HEARD IT THROUGH
THE RUMOR MILL.
THE QUESTION IS DO YOU HAVE A
BUG GUIDE SPRITE?
>> I DON'T.
>> NO, I HEARD THIS THREESOME
PEOPLE IN THE BUCKEYE WORLD.
IT'S A CAR.
I THOUGHT IT WAS A MEDICAL
DISORDER.
AND AUSTIN HEALEY.
>> I HAVE BEEN HK 500.
>> OKAY.
IT'S IN THE SAME AIR HUB.
I DID HAVE A METROPOLITAN THAT
SOLD TO DANA PERINO AT LOSS
BECAUSE SHE CAN DRIVE A HARD
BARGAIN.
>> WE HAD THAT COMMENT I THOUGH
THAT WOULD BE A GOOD WAY TO
START AT OPERATIVE.
>> NO, BUT THAT'S CLOSE ENOUGH
BECAUSE YOUR A CAR JUNKIE AND I
MAKAR JUNKIE.
>> I DO ENJOY THEM.
>> I CAN'T STOP DOING SO MANY
DRAWS ALL THE TAME ALL DAY LONG
DRUGS, HOW DO I COME TO WORK
EVERY SINGLE DAY?
>> HI.
>> INCREDIBLY HIGH.
WHERE AM I?
>> I DON'T KNOW WHERE YOU ARE.
TIGRESS, GOOD TO SEE YOU.
HE ALMOST MISSED HIS FLIGHT
BECAUSE OF THE STORM, BUT HE
TOLD ME YOU HAD TO BE HERE
BECAUSE YOU WERE ON.
>> THERE ARE A LOT OF LIES SAID
IN THIS MONOLOGUE TODAY.
I AM FOREVER AS LONG AS I GRACE
FOR FRIENDS ON THE SHOW THE
ELEPHANT IN THE ROOM.
AND THREE, YOU HAD NO IDEA WHAT
A BUG GUIDE SPRITE WAS, YOU WEN
THROUGH, I SIGHED, EVERY
PERVERTED THING YOU EVER SAW IT
IN YOUR LIFE, WHAT YOU DID WITH
A CAN OF SPRITE I GUARANTEE YOU.
>> AND I THINK THERE WAS CICADA
POSSIBLY INVOLVED?
>> YOU WERE DEEPLY CONCERNED.
DO WE EVEN WANT TO TALK ABOUT
THIS TOPIC?
>> I CAN THINK OF NOTHING I AM
LESS QUALIFIED TO TALK FOR.
THE ONLY THING I HAVE LESS
EXPERIENCE WITH THEM BEING
TRANSGENDER IS PLAYING SPORTS.
>> I'VE BEEN WEIGHTLIFTING FOR
PRETTY MUCH MY WHOLE LIFE AND
COME UP MY ONLY ISSUE HAS BEEN
CONSISTENT THROUGH THIS WHOLE
THING IS WHEN IT COMES TO
GENETICS, WHEN YOU BREAK DOWN
DNA, IF YOUR MORE INHERENTLY
MALE, IF YOU HAVE MALE
TESTOSTERONE COMING OR GOING TO
HAVE MORE DEVELOPED MUSCLES IN
YOUR SHOULDERS AND STUFF WHICH
IS A HUGE ADVANTAGE IN LIFTING.
SO I KIND OF FEEL THERE SHOULD
BE, BUT IN THIS SITUATION, THIS
INDIVIDUAL ISN'T EVEN IN THE TO
FIVE.
IT IS STILL AS FAR AS
WORLD-CLASS GOES, THERE IS AN
UNFAIR ADVANTAGE IF YOU ARE
GENETICALLY MALE IN COMPETITION
BECAUSE THAT'S JUST HOW IT IS.
THAT IS MY ONLY ISSUE, I HAVE.
>> I AM A BUG GUIDE SPRITE.
>> MY HOSPITAL MOCK TRIAL TEAM
WAS COMPLETELY COED.
>> SO IF IT'S NOT IN THE TOP
FIVE BUT WHAT IF SHE KNOCKED
SOMEBODY OUT TO GET HER POSITIO
FROM SAY THE NEW ZEALAND TEAM.
IS THAT WRONG?
I DON'T HEAR ENOUGH ABOUT THE
OTHER HOW THE OTHER ATHLETES
FEEL.
>> FROM AN ATHLETE STANDPOINT I
THINK A LOT OF WOMEN, ESPECIALL
WHEN IT GETS DOWN TO THE YOUNGE
ATHLETES, AT THAT LEVEL, THE
OLYMPIC COMMITTEE HAS BEEN
DEALING WITH THIS ISSUE FOR A
VERY LONG TIME BACK IN THE 60s
THEY STARTED TAKING SALIVA TEST
OF ALL OF THE FEMALE ATHLETES T
MAKE SURE THEIR DNA WAS RIGHT
THIS IS THE ERA OF THE EAST
GERMAN WOMEN THE SOVIET WOMEN,
MEAN I WAS IN THE WEIGHT ROOM M
LAST LIFTING WORKOUTS IN THIS
EAST GERMAN GIRL CAME IN, AND
SHE WAS OUT LIFTING ME.
AND THIS GIRL WAS SO STRONG.
>> ARE YOU SURE SHE WAS A GIRL?
>> SHE TOOK THE TEST.
THEY BEEN DEALING WITH THIS
ISSUE FOR A LONG TIME AND THEY
DO HAVE GUIDELINES, AND
SUPPOSEDLY SHE HAS FOLLOWED ALL
OF THE GUIDELINES SO I HAVE TO
RESPECT THAT, BUT IT'S WHEN LIK
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA,
OBVIOUSLY WHEN IT GETS DOWN TO
HIGH SCHOOL LEVELS WHERE THERE
IS A MASSIVE DIFFERENCE, THEN I
BECOMES UNFAIR, AND THERE IS NO
REGULATIONS AT THAT LEVEL.
AND IT HAS TO BE LOOKED AT.
HONESTLY, IF YOU PASSED
EVERYTHING THAT THE OLYMPIC
COMMITTEE PUT OUT, I AM OKAY
WITH THAT.
I'M OKAY WITH THAT.
BUT NOT AT THE YOUNGER.
>> IF I WAS TESTED I WOULD PASS
A LOT OF THINGS.
>> I HAVE FIVE DAUGHTERS, AND
ONE OF THEM IS A LACROSSE PLAYE
IN HIGH SCHOOL.
THAT'S ALWAYS A BIG CONCERN IS
PROTECTING THE GIRLS SPORTS.
I DON'T WANT TYRUS TO GO AND GE
A LACROSSE STICK AND COMPETE
AGAINST MY DAUGHTER.
>> YOU SHATTERED MY DREAMS.
>> I COULD SEE YOU IN A REALLY
CUTE SKIRT.
>> THAT'S MORE HIS WORLD,.
>> BUT FOR THESE GIRLS THAT.
>> I JUST ASKED YOU TO TRY IT O
ONCE, TYRUS BRETT.
>> FOR THESE GIRLS THAT PRACTIC
DAY IN AND OUT, AND THAT'S OUR
FOCUS FROM DECADES, ADVOCATING
FOR WE NEED TO GIVE MORE
RESOURCES TO GIRLS SPORTS
BECAUSE GUESS HE GETS ALL THE
RESOURCES, THE GUYS SPOR